hi everyone welcome to biology professor
today we're going to be talking about
the cellular process endo cytosis
endocytosis is a very common cellular
process that basically involves the
uptake of bulk material from outside of
the cell so extracellular material and
bringing it into the cell using a
membrane-bound vesicles
there are really three different types
of endocytosis
these are pinocytosis also phagocytosis
or Bejo cytosis and also receptor
mediated endocytosis that third one
receptor mediated endocytosis is a very
specific process that uses a receptor on
the cell surface to bind to some
specific extracellular component that it
is very specific to and bring that into
the cell it's a pretty complex process
that we're not going to talk about today
we're going to be focusing on just these
two here so let's get started
pinocytosis you can think of this as a
process of self drinking basically this
is where the cell uses a structure that
you see here this is called an
invagination
so the cell uses this imagination to
take in basically the liquid or aqueous
environment and all of these small
dissolved solutes that are there and
bring it into the cell into this
membrane-bound vesicles now relative to
phagocytosis which we'll talk about in a
minute these vesicles with pinocytosis
are relatively small
and this is one way that cells get the
nutrients that they need or take up
signaling components and the most common
cells that are using pinocytosis are
liver cells kidney cells and epithelial
cells so skin cells
and so the result of pinocytosis is just
this uptake of small soluble components
into the cell in this process of cell
drinking now let's talk about
phagocytosis phagocytosis relative to
pinocytosis you can think of
phagocytosis as a form of cell eating so
this is when the cell uses these
cellular structures called pseudopodia
so that's plural pseudopodia and
singular pseudopods
so pseudopodia and mana pseudopod and
you still get this vesicle a
membrane-bound vesicles being the result
so the pseudopodia envelop large large
particles these can be bacterias these
can be dead cells and so you can imagine
how large these pseudopodia have to be
to envelop something that large what
happens is the student oh yeah bring
them in via this membrane bound vesicle
which compared to the pinocytosis
smaller vesicles phagocytosis vesicles
are quite large
and the phagocytosis process is very
common to different cells of the immune
system
so specifically macrophages dendritic
cells
and neutrophils
these different cell types can take up
bacteria that they recognize or dead
cells that they recognize and then once
these these components come into the
vesicles they get broken down by enzymes
and this is a way that the immune system
protects us from these these foreign
pathogens and that's the process of
phagocytosis so I hope you learned a lot
today